Jimmy has replaced the roots with a new
band and a super adorable one affect the
late night host daughters Winnie and
Franny were the perfect duo to introduce
Monday's at-home version of The Tonight
Show when he also had a chance to show
off for artistic skills by drawing this
for her dad Monday's episode was truly a
family affair Jimmy's wife Nancy had the
task of the camera operator she also
chimed in just a bit to help Jimmy with
his opening monologue your local food
pantry Google where that is what is
where's my local food pantry they all
need help right now out where I am
Easthampton food pantry was desperate
for anything on the shelves so if you go
stocking up wherever you are just get an
extra can of soup and drop it off to do
it one thing our case of soup or a case
of Jack well if you get a case of soup I
guess people are buying things by their
cases go to Casa go get like a palette
of soup and drop one can up to the top
where you say honey off to the food
pantry well the family moment didn't
just stop with Jimmy's wife his kids or
his dog during his monologue he threw in
a joke written by his sister Gloria
Fallon she said hey guys a lot of us
have entered our second week of
quarantine and I hopefully have enough
food water and skin left on your hands
the late night hosts also shared a
message for those of us who are
practicing social distancing does
walking my dog the other day and and
with my camera operator there's no way
and I don't want this it wasn't I was
walking normal and everyone crossing the
streets is socially distancing which is
great but just because you're doing that
doesn't mean I have to smile or wave you
can do that you don't have to not be a
person
you can be a hello you know you can do
that can't you can you say hello you can
do that Hey
gonna see it I mean we're pulling her
enough away really are Betsey more than
six feet as far as guests on Monday's
episode The Daily Show host Trevor Noah
called in and Jimmy interviewed DJ
dee-nice who's virtual parties have gone
viral well as a DJ you feed off the
crowd right yes and and but you have no
crowd in your kitchen did you still get
the same type of excitement or more I've
ever seen the same type of excitement
but it's actually I've seen more you
know why because when you're feeding off
of the crowd you're trying to you're
trying to play for the crowd like you're
trying I'm watching body languages and
I'm trying to get there I want them to
hear with big bunch of other people were
in that in that blood to hear what I
like and I was able to play from my
heart I love music so I was able to play
stop the music and play Kenny Rogers
like you would never hear Kenny Rogers
in a hip-hop Club you know so I was able
to just see what I loved and it was just
beautiful to experience
[Music]